Let's go next to our caller from the 4:51
area code who is calling today from nine-to-five.
Hi, David.
This is Rama.
Can you hear me OK?
Yes, I can, Rama.
Go ahead.
Right on.
Hey, David, I've been listening to you for
well.
Just before Trump got elected, so thank you,
2016.
I always really dig your takes.
And it took me four years, but I finally became
a member last week.
Thank you.
So there's that.
I appreciate.
And then the youngster that just called before
it.
Before me.
Yes.
16 years old, I believe.
So props to him for being being active and
involved.
So, David, with all the stress that's going
on and things that the world is and the way
it is.
My question is, is.
Would you.
Would you be okay if I told the funny story
of.
Me having the chicken pox in the late 70s
and Richard Pryor, you know, I don't think
that that's a story that is a good one for
this particular show.
And we also only have about a minute left.
So I think I would rather hear.
What are you doing during the quarantine?
Well, so I've been I've been cooped up now
for about a month because both my wife and
I saw this coming.
Yeah.
And so we started social distancing before
anyone even started talking about it.
So we've we've managed to stay inside and
try and get household deliveries as much as
possible.
We've had to go out a couple of times to the
store.
Yeah.
But that's what we're doing.
Thankfully, my wife is a school teacher and
they they had her start working from home
about three weeks ago.
And yet you're not stockpiling like a year's
worth of toilet paper or anything like that.
Well, so I'm an earthquake country.
So you should you should have about a month
of goods anyway.
Right.
And you know, my wife, a toilet paper leg
has gone out of style.
I don't get it.
But, you know, that's the way things are sometimes.
What can you do with that?
So.
Yeah.
You just you know, I love her anyway, so.
Of course.
But I think the reason why I wanted to tell
the story, you know, to make to make a laugh
is because there are some of us that watch
your show that have seen you had a legitimate
laugh when it comes right from your belly.
Right.
And it makes its inpractice infectious.
David?
I'm just saying.
So if.
Well, listen, if you ever want to we have
more time.
We'll do a Richard Pryor story.
And of course, but not nothing better than
than a belly laugh.
Rahmah.
Thank you so much for the call.
It's so great to hear from you.
And I apologize.
I don't have time for that.
More other stories today.
Quick break.
Back after this.